and finally new rule Praise Jesus it's a
Christmas miracle for the first time in
the 21y year history of this show we are
on in December which gives me a chance
to explain to everyone something I've
always wanted to expound upon in this
show you know that whole thing about
Jesus being born on December 25th well
it's a cck of
now this is not an attack on Jesus
although he was a neppo
baby
but also a revolutionary philosopher
with a beautiful message as to whether
he's a God that's up to you but if the
subject is Gods born on December
25th we have enough of those for an
entire Jeopardy
category he was the Egyptian God who
took the form of a falcon who is Horus
he is the god from ancient Persia born
bearing a torch who is Mithra he is the
Greek God of rebirth who is Adonis he
was the fertility God in Cleopatra's
time who is Osiris this Greek de was
known for having a good time who is
dionisis well yeah we wrapped up the
Emmy with that
one
so so you may be asking those are all
real by the way I think that was the
problem they think I'm making this up
but I'm not why do all the gods want the
same birthday well because December 25th
was a p holiday coming a few days after
the shortest day of the year when
primitive peoples noticed that the days
were starting to get longer again and so
a cause for celebration cut
to and that's the story of
Christmas a holiday I love by the way
the tree the presents the music the
Christmas Memories with my sister and
our cousins filling the bong with
eggnog it's the only time of the year
it's okay to put alcohol in
milk Christmas is fun if you just accept
it's pretend time like a Hollywood
wedding yes I love Christmas and always
have just don't try to make me take it
seriously and that is what has been
going on a lot lately here in America we
have a new Speaker of the House Mike
Johnson who says America is actually a
Biblical Republic and that he's even got
a flag picked out that hangs outside his
office and which also could be seen in
the mob on January 6th Mike also says
the separation of church and state is a
misnomer and congresswoman Lauren bobert
concurs saying she's tired of this
separation of church and state
junk so to Marjorie tellor green who
says I say it proudly we should all be
Christian nationalists now I know it may
seem like this is just a few crazies but
I got to tell you dumbass Republicans
who believe horrible ideas are like ants
there's always more that you can't
see and in in fact these ideas are no
longer The Fringe according to a recent
survey over half of Republicans are
either adherence of Christian
nationalism or sympathetic to it and
they agree with statements like the US
government should declare America a
Christian Nation and being Christian is
an important part of being American and
God has called Christians to exercise
dominion over all areas of American
society I'm sorry but I don't want
anyone exercising their Dem minion over
me unless I pay them and we've
established a safe
word bobbert says the church is supposed
to direct the government the government
is not supposed to direct the church
well no and
no neither one is supposed to direct the
other that's what separation of church
and state means Republicans Jesus
Christ first you stop believing
in democracy Senator Mike Lee said it
among others Trump lives the idea every
day and here we have the speaker of the
house saying it and now Republicans also
don't believe in the separation of
church and state does anyone in that
party remember what country
you're living
in
we're the place that Stakes so much of
our greatness on being the first to
specifically prohibit having a state
religion there are dozens of countries
that have an official religion there's
13 where being an atheist is punishable
by
Death
four have Islamic right in the title of
the country and maybe that warms the
hearts of The Tick Tock crowd who lately
have found heroes in Hamas and AMA Bin
Laden but that's not us that's not what
we do here I get it you kids like to
switch things
up but I can only handle one side at a
time being ridiculous about religious
fanaticism and right now I've got my
hands full with Mike
Johnson
because Mike
Johnson because Mike Johnson has the
power to actually make laws and I don't
want my global warming policy decided by
someone who was rooting for the end of
the world so we can get on with the
Rapture and who once filed a legal brief
before The Supreme Court arguing that
what he called deviant samesex
intercourse should be a crime even the
lesbian
stuff Mike thinks God personally chooses
raises up our leaders which is a very
dangerous thought because then when you
lose an election you think it's just
another of God's tricks to test your
faith like
fossils Mike says we began as a
Christian Nation we didn't did you miss
that day in home school
Mike if you don't know that the pilgrims
came here to get away from the church of
England then you don't know literally
the first thing about our
country
Mike Mike says being a Christian Nation
is our tradition and it's who we are as
a people it's not we're the people who
have a First Amendment which says
Congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion and we have an
article six which says no religious test
shall ever be required as a
qualification to any office so I take
these people at their word when they say
that they think we should be Christian
nationalists but then they have to take
John Adams at his word when he wrote the
government of the United States of
America is not an any sense founded on
the Christian
religion but I still love
Christmas